hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca I'm foreign ago and today
we're gonna be covering the new
character your man gander or hobo or
Greta or whatever you want to call him
and also the new breach map I'm doing
this during the exhibition matches so if
everything goes well this should be the
first video and then we'll cover the
reworks and a follow-up video within
like the next 30 minutes or an hour so
of this being live or something like
that so be on the lookout for that we're
gonna be posting a lot of videos today
but for right now we have to talk about
your man Gaynor we get to see some of
the armor some of the weapons the
details and most specifically the
moveset so without further ado like the
V if you do enjoy subscribe if you're
new I covered the informational site a
foreigner that being the balance changes
the hero updates the petrodes and the
leaks if you want to be kept up today
with everything happening within the
world of foreigner and never miss out on
an update every subscribe the channel
and with that let's get started first up
they showed the breach map and the
newest map for season 11 is gonna be
called store fortress it is a new breach
map added to the mix we haven't had a
new breach map since the release of
breach so that's super exciting it's
going to be heavily Viking focused so
that that means the Vikings will now
have to mow or two maps within the
breach game-mode which is really cool
this does look like your typical breach
map loads of destroyed buildings debris
everywhere bridges halls
all that type of [ __ ] is everywhere they
show it looks like a map room presumably
where the warrior guy might spawn if you
want to get those early buffs like in
cozzens fortress where that one warrior
guy spawns up in his temple that's
probably where this warrior is going to
be sitting probably in the map room
looks a bit big enough to fit him there
then a walkway that pursue moogly leads
to the commander and you can of course
play this in day and night cycle so if
you do want to play in the night version
that's always there to for you like the
daytime version that's always there too
I personally like the night version just
by the teasers they've shown overall
like I said it looks like a traditional
biking map and that's a good thing even
though it might just be your traditional
Viking map nothing crazy huge is
happening other than the thing I'm gonna
be showing in a second it's that's the
best part as long as it looks like a
Viking map and it is Viking focused I
think that's a a plus in my book but
there's also this really huge snake
lizard [ __ ] bone thing going on here
by the commander which looks really
creepy and cool-looking and it extends
even outside the map so that's huge I
don't even know what this animal is but
it might be you know your man gander no
little teaser there it's a very large
snake you know that thing is very big so
it could be the bones of your man gander
maybe a symbolism to make it look like
it's your man gander really dope though
definitely liking it so as I said your
man gander is the newest hero in season
11 the female name is Hilda and the male
name is guitar but the actual in-game
name is going to be your man Gander your
man ganders name is actually based off
the giant sea serpent in Norse mythology
so if you do want to know more of the
backstory of this character you can
click the I on the top right for more
info I did an entire lore video or
backstory about the new character but it
also be at the end of this video too
just in case if you want to watch
through this video and then go segue
right into that I don't blame you but
for a quick brief update about his
gameplay he has four chains that's going
to be light light light heavy heavy
heavy and heavy light so he has all the
to move combos he also has a load of new
moves all starting with the word yo tune
like yo tune farewell surge grudge and
gift like I said all of these are gonna
be starting with yo tune and they're
basically the same move it's a bash but
different ways to do it so yo tune
farewell is a punch after any opener
think of like a Centurion punch so after
a heavy attack or a light you can go
right into this bash it does a lot of
stamina damage
yo tune surge is a back step + G B
button once again you can you can do
this now from neutral so if you want to
do something like that you could just go
right into this bash from neutral you
just have to back up and press the guard
break button yo tunes grudge is the
exact same thing as every other bash
that we've talked about except it's from
a parry so if you press G B after a
parry it'll go right into the bash or if
you do happen to gar break the opponent
if you press the light attack button off
a guard break that will give you yo
tunes gift so like I said all four of
these moves with yo tuned at the
beginning of it are all unblockable it
makes sense of the same exact move just
different ways to do it so it really
makes sense that they'd all be
unblockable and they are a bash on top
of that all heavy finishers that you
perform and hit an opponent with and
then the four moves that we just talked
about the yo tune combo of moves can
knock a player on the floor if they're
out of stamina so if the player is out
of stamina and they have to gain it back
if you hit him with any of those moves
like the finisher and the four we just
talked about they'll fall on the floor
kind of like glads toe stab when the
opponent's out of stamina the fault of
the floor think of it that way after on
the floor you can perform this heavy
attack called hammer slam which is a 50
damage move so very very powerful so if
you're out of stamina against your man
gander you better watch out cause you're
gonna lose lots of
he'll permit on top of that all heavy
finishers in the game are unblockable
and all light finishers are going to be
undoubtable and if your light attack is
blocked you can continue the combo as
long as the opponent doesn't have
superior block so most characters like
for example gladiator if you're McGee
Anders fighting gladiator and he's
hitting him with light attacks is if
gladiator blocks them he can still
continue to combo but if it's a
character like with superior block like
Conqueror if the light attack is blocked
and will stop the chain all the
character needs a superior block if they
don't have it your manner can continue
the light attack chain for as long as he
wants on top of that all heavy starters
will have hyper armor and he also has a
new dodge forward heavy called serpent
smite so basically if you do the heavy
heavy combo it's going to be the first
heavy is has hyper armor and then the
second heavy is going to be unblockable
and it's gonna be back-to-back it's
probably not gonna be too big of a combo
no one really throws two heavies
back-to-back that's kind of like an easy
bait for a parry so I'm not really sure
if that's a good idea and also for the
people wondering you could probably see
it in the gameplay but majority of the
moves that he uses if it is a light
attack he will be using one hand and if
it's a heavy attack he will be using two
hands so it is a combination of both
two-handed and one-handed gameplay as a
quick recap this really isn't that big
of a move set which is nice and allows
players to learn and not be confused but
it seems very heavily focused on the
bashes since that's majority of his
moveset let me know what you guys think
I feel the way to play him is really you
do a lot of bash damage then you perform
that 50 damage hammer slam but that's
just me as for the feats we have the
usual four and these are going to be
four unique ones to your main Gander
himself the first feat allows every bash
that you do your man Gander will gain
health on every hit from those bash and
remember you have four ways to pull that
off so that's a lot of health they're
gonna be getting four feet too when you
perform the hem are slim as we discussed
before you'll get a temporary shield on
your health bar both of these to our
passives so you do not need to activate
these by clicking them feet three and
feet four you must activate four three
three you throw your hammer and do some
minor damage but it drains the
opponent's total stamina all the way to
zero and then you can go into those
bashes knock them on the floor into the
home our slime for that extra help from
the second passive but if you're not
feeling that fee for is an AoE slam the
knocks everyone on the floor and if you
have hype and you get hyper armor doing
this and you can follow up into the
Hammar slam afterwards since they're on
the floor which is super crazy
next up is the armor and weapon so for
the armor the design is all about the
Ragnarok prophecy that they believe in
they want Ragnarok to occur and will
stop anyone in their path to achieve
that the armor consists of mostly
leather with some piercings beer changes
hairstyles face paint and scarification
on the face the face is usually the main
factor of change the armor is obviously
different depending on your outfit but
the head pieces I saw looked the most
change per outfit overall the armor does
look great though and I definitely love
it some of the head pieces also have
helmets and masks so don't worry if you
aren't a big fan of having a full face
you can put a mask on it or personally
to me I don't really like having a mask
or a helmet for this character so I'm
going to be using the face paint and for
the face paint it actually changes color
based on your outfit some other things
as well for the default outfit your
player can also be barefoot so glad main
intensify there but you can also of
course wear boots the ornaments are
gonna be on the shoulders and one of the
helmets is actually funny enough matches
the Loki's helmet which totally fits in
with the lore Loki is your man ganders
father so of course the technically you
know this is that's just how that all
fits within the lore so obviously they
would have had adds some type of Loki
helmet in the game and I'm totally cool
with that as for the weapons there's a
lot of differences to each hammer some
have bore heads and Viking logos like
serrated edges many intricate designs
within the piece and then you can change
the handle the shaft and the headpiece a
lot of these look different it's really
really cool I'm definitely [ __ ] with
the designs on this character I
personally like the weapons a lot more
than the armor but that's just me like I
said a lot of different intricate
designs too they definitely spent a lot
of work on these and majority of them
that I will be showing to you of course
they're gonna be going down in the order
some of the lower tier ones you could
totally tell but the higher tier ones
especially the star weapons look
incredibly awesome
so hopefully let me know in the comments
below which one you guys like more
weapons or armor or in specific what
weapon you liked the most
yeah guys that's gonna be the end of the
video hope you guys did enjoy like I
said in the next hour or so because this
stream is still going on but your boy
needs to make these videos you know how
it is we're gonna be showing off the new
reworks and anything else that comes in
that as well as the new season 11
weapons in the future video like I said
in about an hour so stay tuned to the
channel you might be getting a lot of
notifications today I do promise and to
apologize and also if you haven't seen
the season 11 executions I posted a
video about that the the minute they
went live within like a half an hour I
had the video up so thank you all to
everyone that did watch that but if you
did missed that nope
it's not gonna be on the channel okay I
like TV if you do enjoy guys subscribe
if you're new a cover the informational
side of foreign and that being the
balance changes to here updates the
petrodes and the leaks if you want to be
kept up to date with everything
happening within the world of foreigner
as soon as it happens without missing
out on a single update definitely say
subscribe the channel
I mean that guy's hope we have grace
today thank you for watching the video
seen about an hour or so and peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]